たくさんラベリングできる
明確にラベリングできる
すぐしっかりとラベリングできると
すぐできる それで分別能力が開発
発達している 知恵が発達している
知恵が発達しているんだから
あまり時間無駄に使わないで
すぐラベリングできるようになってくるんですね
そうすると次のステージに行っちゃうんです
次のステージは この何でしたっけ？カンカービタラナ
儀がなくなるんだと いわゆる三十一
今日の話 今まであの 前のお話で
これから三十一説明します
カンカービタラナの場合は
一行でこちらで説明してるんですね
テーサンエーワ ナーマルーパーナム パッチェ パリッガーホ カンカービタラナ イスディ ナーマ
その名色の縁の把握を道義清浄というと
で それだけのことなんです
いわゆるあのラベリングすると
すぐラベリングできる人には前のものをラベリングしているでしょ
前のものをラベリングして
次に次の現象をラベリングできる
落とさないんですね 例えば
あ このちょっと前に妄想しましたとかね
そうやって過去のことをラベリングすることはなくなっちゃうんですね
まあ最初は妄想が出たんだけど
これラベリングはできなくて
忘れたとかこといっぱいあるでしょうし
何かちょっと痛みが生まれたんだけど
まあ膨らみ縮むという間で時間なくなっちゃってラベリングできなかったと
かなり時間なくなっちゃうんで忙しくて
この忙しくて時間なくなると
いろんな現象が心は本当はあの監視しているん
監視というかこの認知
認知しているんですけど
このサティで再確認には時間がないんですね
で これではダメですよ
ダメでいたっても人はもうすごい鋭く知恵が開発してもらえないと浄化できるわけでもない
ですから ものすごいこの厳密にこのシステムできてるんですね
だから悟りというのは確固たるものになっちゃうんですね
ごまかしはできないんです
どうしても だからこの知恵が確実に開発する
開発しないと その位置で止まってしまうんですね
だから あなたこういうことを今は一年も観察しているんだから
あの瞑想マンネリになってるんだから
じゃあこういう風にしてくださいと言ったっても
できるかないかと できるならば知恵開発する
できないならば知恵が開発していないんですね
知恵が開発していないと
余計なことにチャレンジするんじゃなくて
自分のレベルで合格するまで頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
とにかくそのそのステージを合格するまで元に戻るということはもう徹底しているんです
それはもう誰のせいでも何のことでもないんですね
だから不思議なシステムなんです
それで 例えばある現象を確認したとする
次の現象をすぐ瞬時に確認できる
次のことも確認できる
次もこれっていうことを確認できる
そういうことで現象AがA確認しました B
次にBだったらBを確認する
次にCだったらCを確認できる B
も確認できるとする そうするとその人にはそのつなぎが見えるんですよ A
確認したところで時間なくなっちゃって
次に確認に行くとそちらがFという現象だったら
これつなぎが見えないんです
なんででしょうかね 前はAでしたけど
今はFですよと 次はJですよと言っちゃえば分からなくなっちゃうんです
例えばとととと行っちゃったら
次はですよと分かるでしょう
それでととと言っちゃったら
次は何ですかね 分からないんですよ
いい加減だから 例えばととと言っちゃったら
次はだからまあある法則はありますね
で だったらまあ次はだと
次はでもでもではなくですよと分かるんですね
まあそこはある一定の法則で
で があって次にだったら次にであるということはすぐ分かっちゃうんですね
それで の次は だったら の次は であることはまた分かるんですね
そうやってこのさっさっさっさっさっと確認できるようになったら
いとも簡単にものの流れを理解できるんです
このものの流れっていうのは因果法則なんです
ですから 別にご自分で方程式を発見しなくてもいいんです
ただ 修行する方々はもう隙間なく確認してみればいいんです
それもずっとできるわけじゃないんですよ
心にもエネルギーの問題ありますから
できる時もできない時もありますけど
それはあんまり関係ないんです
だから続けてやってくださいというのは
やっぱり続けてやると
どんどんどんどん一つの仕事をしかやってないんだから
心はその仕事にもう育てていきますからね
確認作業ね まあそれでこの隙間なく確認する人にとっては何のことなく
これから次はこうでしょうということはもうできるも
だから一つ確認しちゃった瞬間で次はこれっていうことをわかっちゃうと
もう確認もできるんですね
まあ一つ具体的な例を言いますけど
皆様はどうか分かりませんだけど
例えばこのいくら真面目に瞑想したっても
瞬時に心は この眠気の方に行ったりもします
本人気がつかないんです
瞬時に眠りに行って 次の瞬時にまた瞑想を続けちゃうんですから
瞬時だから 心の瞬間だからかなり早いんですね
そこで眠気に陥る瞬間前に昏沈睡眠の心があるんです
これは秒の 分の1よりも早いんですけども
その昏沈睡眠の心は確認した瞬間で
その人がすぐに知ってるんです
昏沈睡眠が生まれると
同時に体に物質も生まれるんだと
そこで体中あの瞬間でだるい物質が生まれちゃうんです
ちっと体中そのだるい物質が流れていっちゃって
で そこであ そうすると確認できるんで
だるくなった その確認できちゃうと睡眠には落ちません
で これはもう鋭い知恵ある人にはできるんです
秒の 分の1よりも早くこの変化を受けると
例えばほんの瞬間 嫌という怒りの気持ちが生まれたりする
怒り 気持ちと確認したりする
怒りの気持ちが生まれた瞬間
体もそれにふさわしい物質作っちゃうんですね
まあわかるか あれは変化でわかるんですね
いわゆる特色でわかっちゃうんです
あるいは作用でわかっちゃうんですね
あ いやって それ確認して
あ 次に体にこういうことやと
もうわかってるんです
わかってるんだからラベリングできるんですね
だから迷うことなく 次にどんなラベリングでいいかというふうに言葉を選ぶことに悩むことなんもないんです
そのようにすごい鋭く観察すること
隙間なく観察することによって
このものの流れを発見できるんです
このものの流れを発見できると
そこには一定の法則があるんです
誰のせいでもないんです
例えば痛みが生まれてくる
心の状態は必ずしも嫌っていう
決まってるんです 痛みが出て
次に欲が生まれるということは
これはもうないんです
そこで嫌味 嫌な気持ちが生まれてくる
次に体もそれなりの変化が起こる
それから次に心にはやる気もちょっと薄くなっちゃう
まあそうやってある まあそれは大雑把なことを言ったんだけど
大雑把でもやっぱり流れが見えてくるんですね
例えば瞑想してしていると
自分がちょっと気が弱くなる
最初からもうやる気が弱いか
やる気が弱いということは
仏教専門用語で集中力の問題で
集中力っていうのはやる気があるっていうこと
興味があるっていうことなんですね
それほど興味がない じゃあやりますということで座るともう姿勢が悪いんですよ
ほんのちょっとでも あるほんのちょっとの姿勢の悪さだから
そこは認識する心にとっては負担になっちゃう
この負担自体からあまり認識したくないってことが出てくる
そうすると確認が大雑把になる
大殺界になると鋭く分別能力は機能しなくなる
それでコントロールなし
妄想が出てくる いわゆる無知の妄想が出てきて
次に昏沈睡眠と寝ると
そういう順番はどんな人間にも同じく決まっているんです
そこで瞑想中 昏沈睡眠が出る
また昏沈睡眠が出たりすると
私は言うのはしっかり座ってみましょうと
しっかり座るためにはいくらかしっかりした気持ちが必要なんです
それに力が必要なんです
で 力が必要になっちゃうと
また心が活性化して上手に確認できるようになってくるんですね
で そのようにいろいろこのシステム
流れ そのそのものの中にあるこの方程式
ということをわかるんです
で 時計の音が耳に入ったとすると
うるさくなったとすると
それ確認できたと それ何回も何回も確認すると
時計の音とまあまあすぐにうるさいということも確認
もう先のことまで確認できるように
なるようになる 先のことまで確認できるようになってきたら
ほんのちょっと なんでうるさいんですかと
なんでうるさい感じが生まれるんですかと
だって音じゃないんですか
それで音としっかりと 二
三回確認しちゃうと うるさいっていうことが出てこなくなった
それであっと自分で発見できるんですね
自分が前はその音はあってほしくなかったんですね
瞑想に邪魔だと だから最初はいか音と確認したんだけど
同時に怒りが生まれたんです
怒りが生まれたんだから
次の心ではうるさいという結論になっているんですね
で 自分がただの音でしょうということで
怒りが作らなかった場合は
うるさいでも気持ちいい音でもなく
単なる音になってしまった
ああ なるほど これ自分のそこで煩悩は絡んでいるんだと
じゃあ煩悩をコントロールできるかというと
いつも簡単にコントロールできるんですね
欲が欲を作るか怒りを作るかっていうのは
それは自分の随分勝手でわかるわけです
あるいは智慧を作るかと
智慧を作る人はただの音やと止める
智慧がないと 綺麗な音だ
うるさい音だとか なんとか判断で見たりする
そこで怒りや欲の煩悩が生まれてくる
そうやってものと認識とそちらにある心の反応と煩悩の流れとかね
で見えてくる 時々嫌なんですけど
この煩悩生まれるのは嫌なんですけど
生まれてくる場合もありますね
自分ではこういう煩悩は生まれてほしくない
でもその現象に出会うたびに
その同じ煩悩が生まれてくる
これ何だろうと そういう確認もできる
例えばみんな人間平等ですから
慈悲でもって対応しなくちゃいけないんだけど
ある人を見るとやっぱり嫌になっちゃう
嫌なんですけど 別にその人のことを恨んでるわけでも憎しんでるわけでもないんだけど
どうしようもないんですね
じゃあどうしようもないんだからって
仏教どうせ放っておかないんですね
どうしようもないんだけど
しょうがないと それは怠け者の考え方なんですね
何だろうと と探すと やっぱり自分がある面ではみんな平等だから
みんなに対して慈しみを持って対応しなくちゃいけないし
ですから慈しみを実践しているんだから
相手の人は憎しんでるわけでもないし
それでも自分には認めたくない何かあるんですね
それでも認めたくない何かあるんですということを発見できるんです
だから そうすると普通の法則と同じだと
そうやっていろんな様々な次元でこのものの流れを発見して見えてくるんです
この状態に なんで疑いの
疑いを乗り越える状態というんですかね
そのわけを 例えば瞑想中カラスの声聞こえだします
すごくうるさくなってくる
気持ち悪くなってくる
ウグイスの声が聞こえたりする
それを確認したところで
音と気持ちも良くなった
それでそれだけでは足りませんよ
それをどんどん確認していく
そこでカラス またカラスの声が入ると
今度は別にうるさいと気持ち悪いとはない
それは自分の確認の仕方が主観から客観になると
そこに嫌な怒りがないんだと
そこでウグイスの声もまた入ってくる
そうすると客観的に確認したとする
気持ちいいとかね そんなことまではいかなかったと
心の中は冷静で そうやって煩悩を作るか作らないかということも自分の勝手であること
それから煩悩を作るためには
過去の経験もかなり影響するんだと
カラスのカラスは気持ち悪いだと
カラスの声はうるさいだと叩き込まれているんだから
カラスの声が聞こえるとうるさくなってくる
だから僕みたいな自然のみんな母親にお前よりは偉いんですよと言われてきたんだから
カラスの声は来てないとうるさいというふうな感覚
我々は持ってないんですね
一番人間と一緒に生活する野生の動物として
だから向こうのカラスなんか人間のことを全然怖がらない
そばに来ているし 例えば外で何か食べ物でも何か整理したりすると
そこら辺に来て ほんのちょっともらったりとかね
外でパンでも食べていると
もうカラスも必ずそばに飛んでくるんですね
飛んできて奪ったりはしない
まあほんのちょっとちょうだいという感じで
で 待ってるんですね そこでもうちょっとあげると
その場合も我々もやっぱりこれ一人で食べるもんじゃないんだと
分けて食べるもんだと
だからカラスにあげましょうということになっちゃうんですね
それですごく優しく親切に食べちゃうと
じゃあ手であげてみようかなということになっちゃう
カラスの性格に人格にもよりますから
手でもらう場合もあります
別に慣れてるわけでも何でもない野生のカラスですけど
ですから そういう風なカラスに対して全然嫌みない文化で育てたならば
もうカラスの声が来たら別に怒りの煩悩が生まれてこない
カラスは怖い動物だと刷り込まれた人にとっては
カラスの声が聞こえると怒りの煩悩が生まれてくる
そこで昨日ある女の若いお母さん見たんだけど
バスに座っていて いきなりものすごい恐怖感で飛び上がっちゃったんですね
すっごい声出ちゃって
飛び上がっちゃったらなんてことかというと
自分の手にテントウムシ 一匹が止まったんです
ただそれだけ 恐怖感 それで見たらテントウムシなんですね
それをテントウムシだと見たところで恐怖感が消えちゃって
そこでそのままその虫を一歳ちょっとぐらいの息子がいたんだから
自分の息子にあげるんですね
あの子供も自分の手でテントウムシを見て
ああ 壊そう 壊そうと言いながら見ているんですね
だから あのちっちゃな子は
子供はなんで壊そう壊そうって
これは母親の感情そのまんま映したんだからでしょうね
壊そうだったら捨てればいいんだけど
全然捨てません それでも
だから子供の本来だったら別に怖いでも怖くないでもどっちでもないんで
ただ興味本位で見ているだけのことなんですね
だからどんな虫が体に止まっても
なんだろうと見る私と恐怖感で怯えて飛び上がってバスに乗ってるみんな
何ですかって思うほどのぐらい感情を作る人と
だからそういうところで
この煩悩には根拠はないんですよ
恐怖感にも根拠はないんです
でも ああいう風に この人間っていうのは自然のものじゃないんだと
人工的でビニール袋で育てるべきですよと思ってるこの文化と
単なる自然の一部だから
自然の中の方が一番いいよと思ってる
文化の中で生まれる煩悩の差がかなり違うんですね
だから私は自分の原始的な文化から考えて
これ余計な話なんですけど
まあ日本は世界的な大きな文化だからね
世界に向けて大変自然大事にするんだと
日本の美っていうのはもう自然そのものを美しくするんだと言うんだけど
現実的な立場から見れば
ものすごい恐ろしく見えちゃうんです
全て壊すんではないか
全て壊す 例えば日本庭園なんかはまあ確かに美しいことは認めます
ものすごい綺麗です すごいんです
でも徹底した人工でしょ
だから私は本当にもう恐ろしさ
なんか殺人みたいな感じになっちゃうんですね
この自然を鉄砲を持って
刀を持って もう壊していく
アンゴリマーラスみたいに
この例えばヒットラー
ヒットラー ヒットラーとかね
ムッソリーニとかね かなり大物でいたでしょうね
世界も怯えてどうだい
私の活動はという感じで
で 同時にそれを褒めていた人々もいましたしね
なんとなく日本庭園見ると同じような
いかに自然を壊したかと
堂々と育てる木をいかにいじめたんですかと
でもまあそれぞれ まあヨーロッパはまた違いますけどね
で イギリスの庭園はまた感覚がまた違いますけどね
イギリスの庭園と比べて
やっぱり日本は自然そのものが石をそのまま置いておいて
そこで苔が出てくるようにしてとかね
あれは全部わざわざと人工的にやるもんなんです
例えばあの もみじですか
あれ なんという木でしたっけ？メープルというあの
で それでも自然には育てませんね
育てられません 育てるようにしません
枝を切って こちらへにこうなって
こうなってほしいと そうするとこちらにある石と
ここに流れてくる水の流れと
こちらにある松の木にぴったし合いますよ
それで後ろにある山と
だから放っておけという人から見れば
あれも殺人なん殺人というか
もう だから私が言いたいのは
物っていうのはそうやって刷り込まれるような状況で見られるということですね
例えばイギリスの庭師が来たら
やっぱり日本のやり方は違うんだと
自然そのものだと 我々は像を作ったり
あの植物でね いろいろ模様を作ったりするんだけど
日本人はそうじゃなくて
自然に放っておいてよと向こうは思うんであって
庭園は作るなと そもそも放っておけという僕から見ればまた感情違うでしょうね
だから煩悩っていうのはそういうそんなもんなんです
どうしようもないということでもないんですね
ですから カラスの声が来たら
全ての人間には必ずしも怒りの煩悩が生まれますよとと思っちゃえば
それにおとぎ話作るんですね
なぜならば 昔々はもうカラス様はもう神様にこういう約束して
そこでこういう約束を破って
それで神様が怒ってカラスにはお前は人間に嫌われるようになりなさいと
もう祟りをかけたんだとかね
ストーリー作っちゃう
そこでそれを信じるようになっちゃうんですね
そんなことじゃないんだと
カラスは嫌いから言ったって
もうある人に もう小さい時からカラスを一羽をね
まあ育ててみれば それすごい可愛いもんなんでね
日本のテレビで見たんだけどね
カラス嫌い日本人なんだけど
ある誰か誰かカラスをね
もう飼って まあちょっと足がもう故障していて
まあ怪我して飛べないというかね
そこで面倒見たところで
カラスはすごいそれに感応させて
いつでもその家にいる
檻に入れてるわけでもないんです
もうカラスに座るとこ
寝るところ作ってあげたら
あんたこっちに来なさいと
もうおとなしくそちらにいる
そこでどんどん日本 人間の言葉も喋る
すごい頭がいいんで すっごく早く喋るんです
そこでどこかへちょっともう散歩にでも飛んできたけれど
ちゃんとあっちこっち飛んでいて
また戻ってきて 教えられてる言葉言いながら
名前で呼んだらまあそこでトコトコトコトコと歩いて
足が弱いんだから 足があまり動かないんだから
まあ変な形で歩いていく
だからもうすごく可愛いんですね
一緒にお風呂にも入ると
そのテレビ見るどころか
まあお母さんが買い物に行くんだけど
じゃあ留守番お願いしますって言ったら
はい 留守番お願いしますとカラスも言うんです
そう言われたらもう買い物に行って帰るまでちゃんとカラスも待ってるんですね
どこかへ出て行かないで
だからそれ見るとものすごい可愛いんですね
ですから そこでその人にとってカラスというのは汚い鳥ですよとか
もう嫌ですよ 怖いですよって煩悩はないでしょう
だから我々言ってるこの煩悩にもそんなに主体性というか
そんなにこのものはないということは
この一点でわかるんです
ですから ずっと観察していくと
ある時はカラスの声を聞いて
やっぱりうるさい やっぱり気持ち悪いと
やっぱり怖くなったとかね
ということはあったりする
それも確認する 何回も何回も確認したりすると
やがて客観的に確認できるようになる
客観的に確認したところで
何の煩悩も怒りも欲もどっちも生まれないんですね
それではなるほど それで自分の主観で煩悩が生まれるのであって
主観だから煩悩を作るかしないかというのは自分の自由自在ではないかと
だから本当のことを言うと
日本の庭園を見てすっごく立派だと見ることもできるし
なんだ面白くないと見ることもできるんです
あるいは私がわざと木を説明した
このこれはもう殺りきやとと思うこともできます
それは皆様には絶対想像できない概念でしょ
だからわざと言ったんです
恐ろしい人間が来て木を切ってねじって
あれも生き物だから だからモミジの木を生き物だと思ってください
自分が左と右も手を伸ばして
さっと上を見て育てたいんです
そこでちょっと病気になって
1つの枝をなんかあまりかっこ悪いんだと
でも本人の体だからね
それで痛いんです それで人が来て左側に入っちゃったら
これ背景の邪魔ですよと
で これ切ると それで切る場合は丁寧に薬塗ったり
何か包帯を巻いたりする
あれに誤魔化せるんですね
大変親切で木を大事にしているんだ
でも私の見方で見てください
ある生き物が自分勝手に自由に自然の中で私も一人の生命だと言って手を伸ばして生きたいんだけど
手を切っちゃいますから
ですから その目で見ると
頑張ってみるとね これはちょっと
残酷的な作りやと思うこともできるし
逆に日本庭園というのは素晴らしいものだと思いたければそれもできます
この周りを計算して人が来たら人の目にどのように映るかと
物は並んでいたっても同じ大きさで並んじゃったら見えませんでしょうに
そこで人間の視覚を勉強して
遠いものは高くなければね
前にあるものは短くなければ
そこで真ん中にあるものは高くなければ
左と左右にあるものは短くなければと
人間の視覚はそういうものなんです
そこで道路を作ると 自分立つところの道路は狭く
遠くは広くしちゃうとまっすぐパラレルで見えちゃうんです
そうでないとね 普通のパラレル道路だったらこうやって細くなって見えちゃうんですね
そこであちら玄関作ってます
例えばいろんな木を立てて
今私は京都にあるなんとかという庭園のことを説明してますけど
で そこら玄関みたいなものがあって
そこでお客さんが向かうんですね
でも道路がずっとまっすぐで見えたら
玄関にすごくピッタシ合うんですね
そこでこうやって見てもさっぱりわからないんだけど
すっごく精密にゆっくりゆっくり広がっているんです
出すところは細くて 向こうに行ったらちょっと幅があると
ほんのわずかなんですけど
そのこちらは例えばまあ 二メートルだったら
あちらは二メートルまあ五十センチぐらいかもしれませんよ
そこはだから人目では見えないんだけど
やっぱり一般人はそうやって映るようにと厳密に計算してこの美を作るんです
それから これこそ自然の美だと感じるように作る
例えば玄関の柱に使っている木は
そのまんま立ててあるんであって
皮は剥いてない それで自然を感じると
本当は枝を全部切ってますけどね
下石の上に立たせて立ててるんだけどね
ですから それなのにいかに目をごまかすかという
あれはもう大変な美学ですよ
だからこの そういう目で見るとまあ評価できると
私の目で見ると それでもこれ貧弱だという
言えます だからこの 自由自在に自分の見方はね
変えられるんです ある人を大変可愛く見ることもできるし
同じ人は全く可愛くないと見ることもできるんです
一般の人の問題はコントロールできないんです
ある時感情に侵されて可愛い可愛いと思ったりして
またいろいろ失望あったりして
同じ人が全く可愛くないと憎しみで見ると憎いと
その法則をわかっている人とどっちでもどちらでも無意味ですよと
どちらでも無意味ですよと
こういう角度で見てみれば
もう可愛い こういう角度で見ればもう可愛くないか
というふうな この煩悩のどのように生まれるかとか確認できるとできます
理解すること だからこの瞑想すると
そんな複雑なことを考えませんだけど
ただまあカラスの声にしたっても
ある時は嫌でうるさくて
ある時はそういう音は別に音はあるんだけど
確認もするんだけど まあ気にならないと
そこで何がわかるんですかね
人間の煩悩と苦しみとかね